[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's a
haunting Mondays yep you guys are always
showing up for this [__] this is a good
episode I watched it twice I re-watched
it again today still tried to make more
sense out of it it's kind of convoluted
it's it's really two stories in one uh I
have a hard time paying attention to a
lot of it because a lot of it's real
samey and your mind starts wandering you
know talking about you mine starts
watching so much like some of the other
ones it's like you've seen it already
and then you go oh wait hold on what are
they talking about now you know so I had
to watch it a couple times
yeah I mean we we watched it last night
and you know as we usually do we watched
it the night before and then like I take
notes real quick but then like we were
talking about other [__] and I had to
keep backing it up and taking notes and
stuff and so I might have missed some of
it too so I'm glad you actually watched
it yeah because I didn't have time too I
don't really know what to make this case
it's supposed to be a demon
because it's demons you know you're
gonna ask did they say it was a demon no
but they well yeah the investigators
believed it was a deep they did okay I
was like I just thought they heavily
implied it was a demon but I don't know
if they actually yeah how do you define
a demon you know
if you look at the Old Testament a demon
can [__] turn an entire
the city to waste and turn people to
[__] to a pillar of salt you know and
stuff so you know they're pretty damn
powerful I don't know what they're doing
[__] around little kids and making beds
shake and [__]
but they think it's a demon
in this story
but a lot of elements in it especially
when the when this guy's a kid
there's a lot of elements of it sounds
kind of like something that would have
happened to my Poltergeist that episode
back in Mount Mountain
disembodied voices coming out of the dam
uh the air ducts for the eating ducks in
the house and
apparitions and
you know just kind of creepy [__]
yeah that would be pretty creepy yeah if
I was worried about that kind of stuff
back at math Mountain if I started to
[__] say man I hope something
something doesn't talk out of the dam
and then it would have done it
doesn't start talking out of the air
duct well don't say it now you say it
too loud because there's a duck right
outside he's having a little he's having
little conversations with it you know
what are you doing in there I live here
you live in there yeah that's like some
[__] yeah wanna be my friend be my
friend
no [__] no I don't it's about this kid
it's that kid who was talking to the
[__] ghost or whatever it is
he's grown up in this house
and then later on becomes a paranormal
investigator
yeah it was like on the side on the side
right and picks up a case and it turns
out it's it's the cases the house he
grew up in is a little kid yeah his mom
kind of like calls him and it's like
yeah
and uh and he tries to get down to the
bottom of this [__] and
um
he loses it's a spoiler alert
he lost to the demon it was just too
powerful well I have to say statement
for him
that is just too much demon for me but
um I have to say whether or not this
affects your
um opinion about the various militude of
this now the Warrens were not directly
involved as far as I'm aware however
Bishop McKenna was and Bishop McKenna
was an associate of theirs and I was
often called in on I don't think the
Warrens they didn't mention the Warrens
on here but they for sure mentioned
McKenna yeah and he's uh he he came to
like a lot of the Warrens cases
but I feel like at the very beginning of
this because remember I said this is
season five and they started to make the
like make it more like a movie so at the
beginning they always do like a little
Flash Forward so the Flash Forward was
Bishop McKenna yeah well I have to go
down to the seller and it was like no
Bishop no it's like two you know what I
mean and then did he fall down the
stairs oh [__] so much [__] happened I
remember if you fell downstairs I
thought it looked like he fell down the
stairs but the way it was edited I was
just kind of like I wrote down then he
fell down the stairs but then like a
second later he was okay and I'm like
well maybe he didn't fall down maybe he
tripped a little bit and [__] went
down a couple steps you know how to do
this like you're walking down and you
Joe Biden out like that I mean I do that
like I I do that just regular I don't
need a demon for that I'm just clumsy it
might have been something like that and
they just added that into the movie see
this is the thing about the haunting
when it gets to season five
they're they're caught them better in
episodes they have there's more
intensity to the voice over in America
there is real evil you know what I mean
it's like damn you know they got his ass
on Roy's yeah they turned the volume
they turned it way up yeah it is it does
have a lot more hype to it
but
there's something less credible about
the tone it doesn't have that kind of
old school laid-back chilled out
documentary feel to it that makes it
more plausible you know this one's gonna
go full horror movie
so which to me like makes it less scary
yeah you have a hard time picking
through
what what the what the Witnesses are
actually reporting in the case and the
story that they're telling and what the
director's showing you because the
director wraps it up
and this one's got cloaked demons with
[__] fangs looking at you with his
yeah and he's got little little teeth
that are like filed yeah and I don't
like I think he ever described it
he didn't really I feel like he he did
say that it had a bloody it had a hood
like a hooded figure but that was
silhouette I think right but that was
pretty much all I'd say he I don't think
he said anything about it having a face
with like little file down teeth or
nothing like that well they thought they
saw a face in the damn
um oh the orbian the orb yeah
look I've seen [__] Poltergeist she's
[__] seen rspk
telekinesis and [__] not really
telekinesis what you call recurrent
spontaneous telekinesis
in in the form of like Poltergeist type
phenomenon
and I've never [__] been convinced
by any kind of damn orb any photography
because there's a million other things
that could be dust
yeah and one of them is this [__]
cigarette smoke in front of the camera
flash the dude's smoking who take the
pitch he takes the pitcher yeah look at
the ghosts
yeah that's called The Flash yeah off
the smoke particles
so um Optics [__] yeah I'm real
skeptical of
I'm just non-believer when it comes to
orbs and I'm skeptical of most of the
Paranormal photographs I've seen
and I'm skeptical of EVPs
most of the EVPs I heard are just kind
of questionable it's open to
interpretation it's not real rocks now
Steve had a couple of them yeah that
were pretty creepy yeah but I think the
one or two that I heard of his that I
was like well maybe yeah other than that
I'm just like I don't even hear what
you're talking about yeah Steve says
there's something to him yeah Steve
Thomas Steve Miller a British pair of
psychologists that we know
Jenny's written a few books with him and
he's had some [__] weird EVPs but
they but the claims he does not make
[__] uh far out claims with the EVPs
that he has it's just it's just an
anomalous [__] voice
we think it says this we don't know
that's that kind of stuff
some of the stuff has to be really
magnified [__] thousands of times
there's no telling you know that's what
I mean the more times you have to turn
it up I'm just like uh it's got to be
[__] I mean you know what I mean
but he would get all kinds of audio
phenomena
something falling on the ground and he'd
record the sound of it there's a remote
recording device there
and I think it was a clock that fell off
the wall yeah no it was like a light
like a one of those lights that you
stick up on I'm just gonna stick them
like right yeah yeah and uh when it hit
the ground
it gave a certain audio signature with
certain decibels and everything and he
knew that that it was the sound of that
light Fallen
but he would drop that light over and
over again and try to get that same
signature and couldn't
the one that
the one that the Poltergeist or ghost
[__] threw or dropped or whatever it
had it was on on unusually loud which
yeah checks out with Poltergeist
phenomenal it was like the same sound
signature but it was like way way way
way louder yeah it's like when the
remote hit the ground it sounded like it
was [__] loud man like a like a brick
hit the ground boom yeah but it's just a
little plastic piece of plastic and then
you throw it pink yeah you know
but it was like well and it didn't even
and it didn't bounce normally it would
bounce it just went like that yeah like
a force had it
yeah it was like a force yeah it was
like pretty weird pulled it through the
ground was like magnetic boom it was
pretty weird yeah but yeah it was really
loud and that's that that was something
that I remembered like I said because of
Steve saying that about that light that
was that um
that was it what's his Face's house
right Keith uh Keith Keith linder's
house yeah Jenny wrote a book about
house of fire and Whispers yeah yeah and
it's just based on the investigation
that Steve Merritt did yeah it wasn't
really based so much on what Keith
lenders well it was a little bit but um
it was mostly like about Steve's in bed
because he was there for a few weeks
someone hit some of Keith linder's
testimonies in it yeah yeah uh but uh
because I think he wrote a book later
too right with his own and if he asked
me I think Keith lender got Driven Crazy
by that phenomenon he just started
reading into it he got obsessed with it
obsessed with it which I get I that's
understandable yeah and I think he
started making stuff up or or imagining
stuff maybe it's a way to put it I don't
know but uh
Steve went there to investigate it and
found some anomalies yeah some weird
[__] did happen when he was there for
sure
but they weren't quite what Steve Linder
was saying they just found some
anomalies yeah I don't know yeah there
was nothing like he had super yeah audio
outrageous but like some pretty weird
[__] did happen yeah like while he was
there but I think it had kind of
I mean at least according to Keith
Linder it kind of like and it kind of
died down died down by the time Steve
got there but he was there for well he
stayed there didn't he for yeah a while
I think so
so he flew over from Britain like and
investigated that [__] like way over to
Seattle
um but yeah we I think we did a show
about it didn't we do a show like so
yeah probably
Zach says I've been down a rabbit hole
of YouTube videos on 4chan horror
stories all afternoon might make a cool
show topic yeah it might
um what are these just the ones where
like the guys like reading the horror
stories from 4chan because I listen to
them sometimes too
but um yeah so you want to get back to
nightmare on Bridgeport I guess okay I
mean we were still talking about
paranormal so it's fine it's related
we're not we're not too far off topic
like not not that that would be any
different but you know well some of the
phenomena reported in this case this
would have been pretty impressive but
you know what I mean to see it it
doesn't quite fit normal patterns that I
would look for but you know it's just a
story yeah
so whether or not Bishop McKenna fell
down the stairs or a trip downstairs or
whatever the [__]
um they just made this big deal about it
because it was like the Flash Forward
you'll see that scene like later on and
then it goes 40 years earlier so
obviously because it's a nightmare in
Bridgeport uh Bridgeport is in
Connecticut which I feel like most
people know so the first part of this
story takes place in 1962.
and I guess they start out with the mom
whose name was Dorothy Baker and her
husband Francis
and they live in this it's them and like
they have two kids Bobby and Robin and
then Bobby you know he grows up and he
becomes the Paranormal Investigator
later on so like I said it's like 40
years ago and then like more recently
so this house was built by
um Dorothy's dad Granddad something like
that
um or some of his some of the family
members like they had bought the land a
long time ago like in the 20s or
something and like built the house so uh
and then the parents like still live
next door like presumably on the same
property so Francis the husband I guess
he was a marine and he works for an
airline manufacturer and then he gets
like another job later on and Dorothy is
you know a homemaker she takes care of
the kids or whatever so like I said
Bobby and Robin are the kids
and Bobby I guess is the older one
and Robin doesn't really factor into it
I guess just as a little girl but I
don't think she was she wasn't on the
show or anything like that so they said
it was very very typical upbringing very
typical family whatever however one
afternoon while they are at this house
Bobby
um and Robin are playing outside in the
yard and Bobby sees this creepy dude
like walk out from behind a tree and
kind of like look at him and he's just
kind of like what that like who's that
like he says to his sister and she's
like who's who what are you talking
about yeah they shot it real well it is
kind of creepy it is pretty creepy dude
just kind of glaring at the kids from a
distance right like somehow Twilight
Zone they're looking and he goes do you
see it and the little girl goes I don't
see what you're talking about he said
that man
threatening him
he just said no he didn't do anything he
just stood there
he said he could feel like you know that
there was something bad about the guy
yeah even though he didn't do anything
he says look at him
so apparently like Bobby tells his mom
like about it and then Robin of course
is just like he's saying thanks you know
what I mean she's like she's you know
like little sisters do and uh so Bobby
got very frustrated that apparently no
one could see this man but him
and his mom didn't really believe him
either and but she did say that it was
kind of very out of character for him to
be like making [__] up like that so she
did kind of take note of it
so apparently later that same day
Bobby's in his room and he's you know
playing with his little army man or
whatever
and he hears this real creepy voice like
calling to him from like the vent like
the heating bench or whatever that's in
his room
and he says
I guess he I don't know how old he was
exactly but he's like I guess it didn't
really maybe like eight or nine I guess
it didn't really occur to me that it was
like weird so I just started talking
back to it yeah like I guess you would
like if you were a kid you're just like
whatever sometimes well no I think I'd
have been like [__] this
to me
mom the devil's daughter
to the vents IMM instantly no I didn't
really quite I think he
I don't think he I don't think he kind
of described it the way it really
happened maybe not because you would
think if there was like a weird voice
like talking to you from out of the vent
you would like [__] your pants I think
that's what actually happened I don't
think like some kid even even a little
kid would be like talking back to it
like it was normal but that's kind of
the way he came across that's probably
how you remembered it oh I cut if that
happened I'm not saying it did happen
but if it did happen there's a chance
that it scared the [__] out of him and
that it intimidated him into into
becoming its friend
and he started talking to it yeah that's
a possibility to me little boy yeah and
then he then he may have forgotten that
he got intimidated into talking to it
because it didn't
it didn't do anything bad to him right
away
yeah I guess not okay yeah so he acted
like it was totally normal he's just
like oh I just thought the voice was
coming from the basement and I was like
and that didn't alarm you why yeah that
there's not a man in the basement I mean
I would be I would be [__] bricks if
I thought that was a man in the basement
that I didn't know about
we don't have a basement but I'm just
saying so um I think it weirded I think
it freaked him out at first and then he
just kind of adapted to it
yeah it's like oh that would have scared
the [__] out of me I don't care you know
yeah that's good it should have me at
six like oh [__] no
I don't know not talking to Yosemite Sam
on a on his [__] Spanish Galleon that
he's full of hot strawberries
[__] a hot cherry pie
caution caution Yosemite Sam's filling
it's hot hot yeah people are like what
the [__] are you talking we've talked
told that story before but I don't know
if people like remember it yeah
I had a dream when I was a little kid
yeah I dug a big Ravine in the front
yard and filled up full of water and I
was putting toy boats in it and walking
around like I was like I was Godzilla
it's like you do yeah and looked
upstream and [__] here comes a big
old Spanish Galleon like where the [__]
did that come
three feet long and I'm looking at this
thing as this beautiful model ship and
I'm looking at it and I get down and
[__] Yosemite Sam about five inches
tall jumped up started shooting at me
going dad damn it
reach down and grabbed him and bit him
on top of his head and it went right
because I thought it was Godzilla went
right through it like the cherry pie
filling and it was hot it burned my
[__]
right out of McDonald's that's not six
and I remember that through the [__]
[__] Yosemite Sam yeah I couldn't
process blood I didn't want it to be
like blood and gore so right the next
leap to soften that in my mind it's like
McDonald's McDonald's Cherry Pie film
but hot right
yeah I guess so I guess that's why
that's why you that's it because it
sounds weird like when you first say it
but when you say it like that I'm like
oh okay that makes total sense yeah that
makes little sense yeah I mean it
doesn't make total sense that Yosemite
Sam was on a Spanish Galleon in a yeah
in your yard yeah shooting at me
shooting at you yeah it wasn't a cartoon
oh really you never told me that I was
imagining that he was like animated no
he wasn't a cartoon he looked just like
a cartoon but he was like uh like
three-dimensional oh yeah he's
three-dimensional you had fur and hair
and [__] clothing and everything and
guns cute maybe he looked just like the
just like the cartoon
that's awesome yeah
it's kind of it looked kind of like with
those you know like the claymation yeah
yeah that's what I was imagining yeah
it's not really claymation that wants to
live to Hollywood movies like this like
this CJ yeah yeah yeah and it's like
that yeah that wasn't clay that was um
little dog like little dolls like
Armature yeah yeah
like the um what the [__] Rankin bass
yeah what what's the matter we gotta get
back
there pokey's complaining yes
yeah so
you're gonna be on the show whether you
like it or not you gonna sit still
reaction okay just chill out okay
um yeah stop motion thank you I could
not think of that phrase to save my life
so uh so yeah so he hears this voice
coming from the vet saying uh you know
are you down to the basement he's like
yeah I live down here he's like want to
be my friend and I'd have been like
kid's like oh sure yeah okay
um so yeah so he does I guess he tells
his mom about some of this stuff but she
thinks he's just imaginative you know
so in the next scene Grandma shows up
because remember I said the mom the
parents like lived in the next house
over or whatever so apparently she comes
over to like help watch the kids because
Francis the dad um he's working two jobs
and he's never home
now Grandma for whatever reason she's
like here kids gather around we got
cookies and tea and all this other stuff
but Grandma's gonna tell you a story
the story is about when Grandpa first
bought this land back in the day and
started building this house it's like
you know when they were digging the
foundation for this house guess what
they found human bones you know what I'm
like that's probably not an appropriate
thing to be telling like little kids but
okay that's old people they look it they
don't give any [__] they're like [__]
them okay
hopefully they wet the bed tonight
they're gonna have nightmares but yeah
so she's like basically I love this
she's like so Grandpa they find bones
underneath I thought the implication was
that it was just one skeleton but then
later on it's kind of implied that maybe
it was two but they found human bones
and because they didn't want to
um stop working on the house so they're
like we're just gonna we're just gonna
like put those back where they were and
we're not gonna tell anybody so they
didn't tell the authorities or anything
because you know Grandpa reasoned uh you
know pretty logically I guess that it's
like well they're dead so yeah so who
cares and then Grandma had to like kind
of back it up a little bit and justify a
little bit more well you have to
understand it was almost winter time and
then like if they didn't get the
foundation dug then they'd have to wait
all season and stuff like that so I was
like okay whatever so they just didn't
want to like you know tell anybody about
the body he said they thought it was
Native American boats yeah so they're
just like just throw it back in the hole
we're just gonna pretend we didn't see
it there were old cemeteries Long
forgotten yeah
I mean technically I guess if you find
bones you're always supposed to call
because it could be a murder victim say
like you don't know but um yeah but they
but they didn't
now the mom comes in at this point is
like Grandma why are you well you know
it's not her grandma it's her mom
obviously but she's just like why are
you telling the kids that it's like
they're gonna have nightmares and stuff
she didn't seem too upset about it
though grandma was like what you know I
do what I want right pretty much
grandma gives no [__] yeah so
so uh for the next several months
apparently Bobby has been talking to his
imaginary friend he never did give him a
name though did he not that I I didn't
write it down anyway Mr Hanky
who lives in the vent yeah
you smell it yeah
it's a little stink lines coming out but
um it's like [__] Pepe Le Pew or
something or Pig Pen
um so his mom like just gets used to it
she's just like whatever I guess he's
just got an imaginary friend now
um there's also there was also a scene
too where like the phone rang they
didn't really go too much into this but
the phone rang and then the mom answered
it and it heard like a weird creepy
sound you know how in movies when you
know there's a ghost afoot and like
somebody in the phone rings and you pick
it up and they're like you know like
that weird kind of sound on the phone so
she hears that
and then she goes back in the living
room and Bobby is suddenly like
disappeared and she's like where the
[__] did that kid go you know what I
mean and then she's like looking all
around and then she finds him hiding
behind the couch and she's all like what
are you doing back here and I'm hiding
I'm hiding from my friend because
apparently the friend that he had been
playing with all of these months that
had been he used the term playful up to
this point even though it didn't sound
really painful playful from the
beginning it sounded like really ominous
but uh apparently turned malevolent and
said that he was trying to push Bobby
into doing bad things that's pretty much
all they said about it though because I
don't know
apparently the demon was never
successful in getting Bobby to do any
bad things because he didn't bring that
up yeah you know what I mean so uh so I
don't really know what bad things he was
trying to talk him into doing oh man
said I could right that's what I'm
saying he wasn't peeing in the closet or
trying to squish the kitty or anything
like that
um so thankfully yeah but um yeah he
didn't really say that he did anything
bad so he was like resisting the [__] I
guess
also a little while later Bobby's in his
room sleeping and then there's kind of
like this white flash of something or
other and then he goes to the window to
see what it is and the window's open and
then he sees the all the um laundry is
like hanging out on the line and it
starts acting like one of the things
like starts blowing really weird like
unnaturally and then it comes off and it
like flies in the window at him so he's
like attacked by a sheep right so so the
Demon's like trying to kill him with a
sheet which
you know yeah seems a little yeah it
seems a little lame for a demon
[Laughter]
Whispering Bobby's name and it's like oh
I'm gonna kill you with a sheet I'm like
oh okay my Straight Clan's been on I
guess he did
maybe that's what he was doing maybe
that's one of the bad things that he was
trying to talk him into doing yeah once
you put join in the clan yeah once you
get this big cross yeah that's what the
team get that down and submit gasoline
maybe that's why they didn't go with the
specifics
his little kid like get a little bitty
click yeah [__] it out yeah oh my God
if anybody ask you your name you tell
them you're the grand wizard she's
the great Cyclops
so yeah so the sheets in there
suffocating again he's screaming his
little head off
so the next morning uh the mom probably
thinking that Bobby is losing his
[__] marbles
um calls a doctor to come have a look at
this kid because what the [__]
um you know the kid's not sleeping
doesn't have any energy stuff like that
now the doctor looks at him and says you
know there's nothing physically wrong
with the kid maybe he's just crazy no
she doesn't do that
so a few weeks later
um Bobby like Bobby and uh the mom are
like sitting at the table like in the
kitchen
and Mom asked him to go to The Cellar to
get some jars because she's doing some
some jam and stuff like that but
um he said and they didn't really do
like a lot of build up to this but he
said he was like really terrified to go
down to the cellar because I guess he
thought that that's where well that's
where the voice was coming from at least
he perceived it so he was like scared to
go down there so he was basically like
Mom I don't want to go down to the
cellar and she's like would you quit
being such a [__] like put your big boy
pants on and get your ass down there and
get me a jar so so he goes down there
and then he hears like a that shadow
that that voice like kind of calling his
name or like Bobby be my friend and then
like he looked over and apparently he
saw the thing
I mean that's what he that right I mean
he said that he saw it he saw it like
the hooded scary man like standing yeah
in the corner yeah but then I put in my
notes right here I put Bobby drops his
nuts that's right that's what little
nuts he has yeah the kid was like eight
or something so they're not even dropped
yet
well they dropped to that day they
dropped dead when you find a [__]
demon you automatically become a man
I mean I kind of feel like yeah
yeah so he's saying like his kid self
all he had to do was go down to the
cellar he did like drop the jar because
he was scared and stuff but he basically
said I decided I wasn't going to take it
anymore and I just like started like I'm
not afraid of you blah blah and also and
the demon was like oh you know what I
mean so I guess that got rid of the dude
he threw something at it oh he threw the
jar at it yeah okay so that I wasn't
watching it hit the wall behind it hit
the wall and the demo was like Oh and it
kind of dissipated
I am defeated and then his mom came
downstairs why'd this glass break and he
was pissed off you know I'm fighting
this [__] demon down here she's like
sure you are honey
[Laughter]
you just didn't want to get the jar and
you just like her BS about it too much
Dungeons and Dragons
[Laughter]
maybe before Dungeons and the dragons
wasn't it I don't know I think this was
the 60s okay yeah yes this is before the
dragons
yeah so he was just getting that right
his mind his mind had not been twisted
imagination run wild
systems it'll systematize all of your
[__] um uh ideas about monsters how
strong are monsters so when you're a kid
you just think yeah a monster is a
monster but how strong is one monster
compared to another monster and how
strong are they compared to a people
yeah and like what happens if they fight
and how do you fight them so you know
that that's what d d was all about is to
put those goddamn monsters in
perspective
and when you're a young kid man [__]
that's awesome you now have you have a
way of [__] system systematically
organizing it's monster cladistics
you're afraid might exist
[Laughter]
that's what it is yeah
so uh so yeah apparently just a little
kid
uh you know standing up for himself and
throwing a jar at the demon dissipated
the demon for 40 years so not bad I mean
the kid did better the spoiler alert
later on than the than the paranormal
investigators in the bishop did so you
know gotta give them something something
there kid nuts intact
right yeah so uh so yeah so he says
nothing happened again for the next 40
years
and he just lived a normal kid life and
grew up as kids too
so uh Bobby ends up growing up and
becoming a child safety specialist and
on the side he's a Paranormal
Investigator because you know a lot of
these people that have these kind of
experiences as kids become paranormal
investigators they did say they want to
help other people and stuff so it was
called Connecticut paranormal
investigators I guess was the name of it
so uh Bob is visiting his parents at the
same house that he grew up in
now he's helping them take care of his
dad Francis because his dad got uh
Parkinson's and like he had dementia
now dad
um they're kind of walking him through
the living room one day and he gets this
really terrified look on his face and I
guess he told them that he saw two
people sitting on the couch like a man
and a woman and obviously nobody else
saw them
so obviously they just attributed this
to dementia they thought that he was
like hallucinating or like seeing stuff
but you know maybe not we see how that
goes later on
so uh dad passes away finally and
Dorothy the mom now lives in the house
by herself which she has never done
before obviously because her and her
husband have been married for a very
long time
so she's kind of like she starts hearing
Whispering around the house she said it
sounded like a conversation on a TV or a
radio but one that was like really
really far away yeah that's kind of
creepy when she said that yeah that's I
thought that was creepy so it's a little
[__] that creeps me out me too me too
I'm always like way creeped like I said
the when they show like ooh demon face
and stuff with fangs and I'm just like
meh it's just not right I mean yeah if
you saw that in real life yeah that'd be
scary but it's just like I don't know in
a movie it's not really that scary
subtle [__] is scarier too yeah I don't
know why it just is that matches up more
with the experiences I've had with the
what people would call a paranormal me
it's just kind of normal but [__]
it's a little bit subtle but it's real
yeah yeah like out of body experiences
near-death experiences dreaming true
having premonitions
Poltergeist
finding bad houses that I guess they
might be haunted you don't know but it's
just it's a bad house
some watching you it's subtle
they didn't really mention feeling
watched in this house yeah they didn't
yeah that was one of the few that they
didn't really say that
so so the mom hears this and she's like
At first she was weirded out but she
wasn't really scared at first because
she thought it was her dead husband like
she said because he always said that oh
he would never leave her he would never
leave the house or whatever so she would
talk to it like it was him
um but after a while she started to feel
like yeah it's probably not him it just
wasn't it wasn't the France's energy you
know what I mean I guess
so one night she's kind of she's
sleeping in the bed and she said she
felt like a really strong presence in
the room and it like woke her up and
then she felt somebody sitting on the
foot of the bed and she said that you
could just like feel that it was evil or
whatever
so the mom at this point is like yeah
that's not my dead husband so maybe I
need to do something about this so she
calls her son Bob who obviously is a
Paranormal Investigator and uh it's just
like you need to come over and check
this [__] out because like I said some
some haunting Shenanigans are going on
over here
now he said even though
sin he had all that scary [__] happened
to him as a kid he seemed like he didn't
really take it all that seriously at
first like he just thought oh you know
mom's just wigging out because she's old
and this is the first time that she's
lived in the house by herself and you
know she's just getting spooked or
whatever so he didn't really take it all
that so he's like I'm just gonna go like
look around and investigate just to make
her feel better you know what I mean he
was like a little bit condescending
about it
so um he goes there and he does like
some EVP [__] and all that other kind of
stuff but he said he doesn't feel
anything unusually to feel any like dark
energy or oppressive anything or anybody
watching him or nothing like that he
said it just felt normal
but then uh when he's doing the
investigation he said that he heard
footsteps like coming toward him and
then he said he suddenly felt like a
presence in front of him and then he
also felt like nausea and like anxiety
like his heart speeded up or something
like that
so uh so yeah so he's starting to think
oh [__] maybe there is nothing in the
house
sells mom well tell you what just get
the house blessed but he tries to he
doesn't tell her about like what he felt
or anything he's trying to like downplay
because he doesn't want to scare her but
she kind of knew that he was doing that
and you know what I mean like that he
wasn't being entirely truthful
so he decides he's gonna bring in his
team so it's like two other people I
think their names were Jim and Mary I
think is what they were Mary was the
sensitive the psychic person so she goes
in first and she's like most of the
psychics on the show is always like I
always want them to not tell me anything
about anything blah blah blah you know
what I mean
so she goes into the house
and in the living room she said she
sensed the presence of a man and woman
like sitting or around the couch which
was the same place that dementia dad had
seen the two ghosts and they thought
that he was just like seeing [__] but
now Bob is like oh maybe dad did see
something and now I feel kind of bad
because we were just like oh there's
nothing there but maybe he was like
really seeing something because I guess
this woman didn't know anything about
that
so Mary goes into Bobby's old bedroom
and you know sense is the evil presence
in there and uh she's like yeah we also
need to investigate the seller and we're
gonna battle that dark entity as we do
so they go down to the seller and they
said it was like real heavy and
oppressive down there like something bad
happened like some kind of tragedy now
this the psychic says that there are
spirits attached to the land but not the
house necessarily and um she said that
she had a vision of a body being carried
and dumped on the property
and then she looks over in the corner of
the basement and sees the hooded scary
dude and describes it to Bob and
apparently she saw the thing in the same
place that he saw it when he was a kid
and it looked the same as like when she
described it it looked the same as what
he had seen so to so he to him that
seemed like Vindication because like
okay I wasn't imagining it because she
saw the same thing I don't like I said I
don't know if that's the case or not but
that's what they said anyway so the team
like stays overnight in the house while
Dorothy the mom is sleeping and they're
looking at the photos and in one of the
photo like most of the photos aren't of
anything but like obviously there's one
of it was an orb in it and we're just
like oh okay whatever an orb
um but then this orb is like a special
orb because this orb has a demon face in
it right which he's like looking at he
blows it up and he's like oh my God it's
the same demon face I'm like obviously
they took the mask of the actor of the
[__] videos
yeah I want to see the original [__] see
well see they never show it though I
mean we always say that we always say
like you got a [__] photograph of a
whole demon face and you're not gonna
[__] let us see the original you're
gonna oh we're gonna hide that that's
too good
we can't we can't let you please look at
it or like oh oh the demon face yeah we
lost that
you know we lost it
we have to you lost a photograph of the
day of the Demon's face okay either that
or they'll say like well we all saw it
but then like when we went back to look
at it the next day it was gone yeah like
the thing was gone it looked like a
normal picture or they'll come up with
something like that it's always some
excuse why they can't show it to you
they can't show you the original all
right
it's like you know what I mean it's just
like oh this videotape that I had with
all this evidence on oh somehow it got
magically erased or yeah can't show you
this they always have some kind of
excuse you know just convenient that's
all I'm saying
so uh so yeah so while they're looking
at the at the demon face orb uh
apparently someone invisible is sitting
on mom's bed and kind of like pushing
her she said she felt like two hands on
her back just sounded neurotic but I
know she's like oh well maybe it is her
husband after all they're pushing you on
your back
pitch raise it up
oh my goodness
this is getting into a whole weird area
here
cross-dimensional [__] yeah sure yeah
I mean you know there's brother it's got
to happen there's a whole sub genre
it's like ghosts and humans yeah there
was even a couple movies like that
Truly Madly Deeply was the one that
comes to mind goes to Mrs Muir yeah
there you go there was another one too
that I saw that happened that took place
in Wales what the [__] wasn't even that
I can't remember her name but it was
pretty good
um so Bob decides uh because the ghost
is getting a little aggressive with Mom
there
that um he's gonna move mom in with him
because he thinks you know the ghost is
gonna hurt her or something like that
so at this point they call in good old
Bishop McKenna like I said
um this he's a he's a Warrens associate
I'm sure he's been on other cases too
but he it just seems like whenever they
because it's Connecticut you know what I
mean uh where the Warrens that's kind of
the Warren stomping ground so whenever
they needed like a big mukety muck
religious person to come in they always
called this dude so he comes in uh to do
a blessing on the house
and they said they noticed like or the
psychic or whatever like notice that the
spirit seemed a lot more agitated like
when he came in because you know just he
just pisses all the spirits off when he
comes in to like oh this [__]
so um so then there's like a whispery
voice and then I put McKenna falls
downstairs but I guess he didn't really
fall downstairs I guess he just kind of
would like the thing pushed him or
something like that I don't know
so at this point they're all kind of
down there doing this exorcism kind of
jazz like down in the basement and they
were all kind of feeling like the demon
really really did not want to leave and
they all said that they felt like really
weak and worn out
um and they were like well they thought
maybe it wasn't gonna work because the
demon was being a real [__] and like
was not wanting to leave despite all of
their prayers and whatnot
now after a while like I guess they did
this for a while
and um Bob was like well at the end of
The Exorcism I was pretty sure that I
thought it worked
um but then later that night it okay and
this was not super clear
on that night it seemed as though uh the
demon pulled the old sheet trick again
yeah trying to get him to join the clan
yeah
well like a little bit in there okay
where where he like pulled the sheet and
like could just pull it like tight
against him like he was gonna suffocate
him or whatever yeah so that happened
and I was like wow that would be really
alarming if that happened in real life
but then I thought he said something
like
the way the way that he phrased it made
me think that it was a dream
because then he kind of came they showed
it and then he kind of came and said
well I'm having nightmares like that so
that must mean that the demon isn't gone
or that the exorcism didn't work and I
was like so are you saying that that
really happened or that that was a dream
or what's the deal must have been a
dream I I that's what I was saying some
of the some of this episode's kind of
confusing because it does some of that
and when you're watching it your mind
will kind of skip right over it Without
Really analyzing real quickly they kind
of trick you right
he probably was dreaming it
that was the impression I got but they
wanted to make it seem like he wasn't it
really happened but the way that he
phrased it like afterward I was like
wait you you sounded like you just said
that it was a joke
which but which made me wonder like when
the [__] when the sheet [__] happened to
him as a kid the sheet [__] the sheet
[__] yeah when that happened to him as a
kid was that a dream too then because
they made you think that he that that
really happened yeah no I think that
really did happen
I think like it flew in the window and I
think so try to suffocate him man I had
to see it again I think he did it you
watched it more recently than I yeah but
I'd have to see it again some of that
[__] you just kind of skim over it yeah
that's true Without Really analyzing
well I'm trying to pay attention but I'm
also trying to like write notes down at
the same time so like sometimes like so
much happens so quickly sometimes you
can't absorb it yeah you know this
happens and this happens this happens
and you forgot it right
so the fact that this this whole sheet
thing happened again whether in a dream
or in reality we're not entirely sure
um indicates to Bob that the exorcism
did not work
so he says over the next few months they
keep going back to the house and keep
doing like blessings and exorcism like
all different kinds you know what I mean
I don't know how many kinds there are
but they're doing all the different
kinds uh but apparently nothing works
they call Bishop McKenna back again
and he does the second deal with uh holy
incense and this made us laugh really
hard because
they're like so he wanted to make sure
that every corner in the house had like
incense in it yeah and so they have him
coming out of the house and there's
literally like smoke like billowing at
them like did they burn it down what the
[__] is going they must have smoke in
every corner of the river I'm like they
weren't hidden yeah
and they had to come back a week later
yes
yeah then they said A week later this I
was like it took a week to clear the
smoke out yeah how much [__] it says
did he bump into that [__] it was just
like so funny because I just thought
what I thought was like Bishop McKenna
it would be funny if he like came out
and he's just like the demon is too
strong to like [__] this place and he
just like throws a match and it blows up
or something because there's just like
all of this smoke coming out like he
just decided [__] it I'm just gonna burn
it down that's like what I thought I
don't know it was just like really funny
to me like all that smoke coming out and
then the fact that it they said that
they had to stay away for a week
I said it was just like they fumigated
it like I did in my apartment back in
the old days so uh so yeah
so Bob and Jim which I think was the
other guy's name like on his paranormal
team
um they keep going back to the house
because they still keep trying you know
they're gonna try and defeat the demon
or whatever and so they're in there like
sitting in the kitchen sitting on the
kitchen table and they start hearing
footsteps again
and then they both kind of like stand up
and he said they felt like they were
both having heart attacks which in a way
that would be [__] up if that really
happened but it's like kind of funny the
way because they're both kind of like
clutching their chests and like you know
flailing around on the floor and stuff
like both of them at the same time and I
was like okay that's a little silly but
yeah so um yeah spiritual attack so uh
so they both felt like they were like
their hearts were racing or whatever so
they're like okay we need to get the
[__] out of here so they both like ran
out and [__] out the house and like in
the yard
um so Jim basically says they're just
like out in the yard going you know like
I'm not like all like that so Jim's like
we can't we can't do this anymore the
demon it's it's too strong for us it's
too strong for us so um you know maybe
it could kill us probably you know so
which that you know that sounds fair so
Bob says uh yeah I think you're right
and we're just gonna this whole [__] is
like a write-off
and Bob says uh that he never went back
to the house and he didn't let his mom
go back either and he said he felt
really bad because you know the um his
mom like I guess his granddad had built
that house like for her and they had
lived in it like their whole entire
lives and she apparently left all her
[__] in there like they just left all of
it there and she wouldn't go back in the
house afterward that's what they said
anyway
um that's the story we're giving that's
so yeah I don't know if it's true or not
I'm just saying what they said on the
show I'm making no claim for how true it
is they left it there for a few weeks
and then the movers came and picked it
yeah they get it yeah it was like yeah
because you can just get movers you know
like even if you didn't want to go back
in the house because it's haunted you
could be like well you just pay some
movers to go in there just get all my
[__] out you know what I mean but um
because you know I have to make jokes
about stuff but there was like a scene
where Bob uh you know the actor that was
playing Bob was talking to the actor
playing the mom and he was saying I feel
so bad like I didn't help you and like
you can't even move back in your house
now and you know I'm I let you down or
something like that and then of course I
had to make the joke like as the mom I
was like you've let me down your whole
entire life Bob
why should now be any different but no
um I'm sorry I'm just being mean but um
but yeah so he said he felt really bad
because he couldn't help her you know
what I mean but you know it's a demon
what are you gonna do uh it was too
strong for them and I guess they
couldn't uh do anything about it so I
guess the mom like kept saying with him
you know from then from thence forward
and they said that neither okay the
narrator says neither one of them ever
went back to the house and no one else
did either and I'm like and I find it
hard to believe that that house was
empty all that time I mean
because you still got to pay for it
right yeah what what is it what is it go
to the state becomes part of the county
well I mean after a while if it was paid
off then it would still belong well if
it was paid off it would still belong to
you so you could technically abandon it
and it would just sit there and rot yeah
um but if you still had a mortgage on it
then after a while the bank would
foreclose on it and then they would
resell it like um for much for a much
lower price to try to record some costs
on it or not or tear it down yeah the
bank owns a lot of [__] that's just
sitting there rotten to this day yeah
well I mean I imagine they own a lot of
stuff and they don't have the resources
to like [__] with it so I don't really
know so I don't know what it what ended
up happening to the house you know what
I mean they said that nobody else ever
lived in there but I don't know if
that's the case or not like I said I
find that hard to believe but you know
it's that could possibly be true and I
think this show came out in
2012. yeah I think season five was 2012.
so I don't know like if the mom is still
alive she looked pretty spry like on
this show she didn't look terribly old
so
um so she might still be around I'm not
really entirely sure it was a good
episode yeah yeah this was a fun episode
but like you said the ones that because
there were a couple
um episodes like the one with Billy Bean
and all that kind of stuff where it's
kind of like oh I had all this weird
[__] happen to me like as a kid and then
I got older and became a Paranormal
Investigator and then I ended up going
back to the same house and I think the
same thing happened to Billy Bean right
basically yeah right like so it wasn't
the same house
I don't think was it I thought it was
the same house or like or his parents
house or something like or you know
something I don't remember but it's I
kind of feel like it so this was one of
those I have a narrative to it there's a
lot of there's a lot of this yeah I was
a kid and I was a sinner and I saw the
devil and then later I became saved and
went back and fought it and won yeah see
that's that but that's not exactly what
happened in this one but that's the the
basic
story yeah because this one wasn't I
mean they called in the bishop and
everything like that but this one wasn't
like super super religiously right even
though it was about a demon and [__]
like that but nobody saw any Angels or
you know anything like that so it wasn't
I don't know it was kind of religiously
but not as religiously as some of them
are yeah salvation stories
yeah that's why I'm always really
skeptical about I mean I'm kind of
skeptical about all of them but I'm
gonna be more inclined to believe ones
that didn't really have a religious
component to them where that was just
and also didn't have like a narrative
component to them where it's just like
we moved into this house in just this
weird random [__] happened and we
couldn't explain it at the end and
preacher salvation stories uh that they
they come in a lot more varieties than
just paranormal some preachers will have
a paranormal background some preachers
will have a background in prison oh I
was a criminal a Satanist I [__]
sacrifice babies that went to prison for
a minute came became saved and came out
free and now I'm a preacher and I'm
helping all you people that's another
one another one is uh uh yeah oh yeah I
was uh a bad girl uh fell to the life of
sin and drugs became a porn star blah
blah blah [__] a billion dudes and uh
but now I'm saved and now I'm [__] a
billion and I married your preacher so
I'm the wife of a Preacher you know and
I mean I ain't no ho you know this is a
Salvation story you know it's anti-host
and to be honest I think a lot of that
[__] is made up I mean obviously
probably well they're a confirmed porn
actresses that became preachers oh yeah
I'm not saying that doesn't happen but
I'm saying like the real outlandish ones
that were like oh I was in a satanic
yeah we ate babies and stuff I'm like
you did not knock it off they had dudes
I remember that they had dudes in the
80s that were claiming that yeah in the
80s remember that dude yeah yeah yeah
yeah and it's like it's up on Geraldo
because they knew all about it because
it's like I knew I'm like all about it I
was born and it's in your [__]
imagination get the [__] out of here
made that [__] up they did I know
exactly what Judas Priest lyrics mean
it's very breaking the law is about it
it's about breaking God's Commandments
it has nothing to do with crime
all right
yeah I guess I never even thought of
that what's that I never thought I never
thought that it could be interpreted
that way yeah I always just thought of
it as just like oh I'm breaking the law
I'm driving really fast like I'm doing
uh no in the lyrics Rob Halford plainly
says that he's out of work and down and
he's it oh so so frustrated it's a trip
from town to town they don't know what
it's like nobody even cares I don't care
you know that you if you were like me be
doing the same thing too I'm breaking
the law breaking the light just becomes
a criminal
so just like a a non-specific criminal
um well you hear breaking glass in the
back in the background of the song so
he's dealing he's looting he's looting
[__] yeah
so I'm taking this breaking into
business taking this TV taking TVs and
yeah stealing some VC and then fencing
them yeah
that'd be really funny if like Rob
Halford was fencing BCR yeah
you're not fit
having respect for Crime man takes what
he wants he opens his leather coat and
there's like all these like watches and
stuff yeah that's right
only a hoe would have [__] taken from
him that's right
they owe it to you
Society
yeah I guess that's dominant as [__]
yeah that's pretty hilarious yeah I
understand the letter let me tell you I
don't understand the total high
testosterone leather daddy mentality man
[__] I know exactly what they're
talking about
yeah we were listening to the car the
other day yeah
[__] I love Jesus
70s Judas Priest was the best though
like Sad Wings of Destiny and after sin
beckner's kind of slightly Prague Rock
and [__] the lyrics were better if he
asked me like The Sinner [__] great
song man
their lyrics are pretty good I I do kind
of feel like
um
I think that one of the reasons that I
never really got real into
metal and stuff like that is like a lot
of the lyrics are really like on the
nose yeah who knows but but not not like
not like Anvil level yeah which is like
the ultimate right that's the ultimate
[__] speaking about moth red [__]
and they're just describing what's
happening in the movie
Alfred [__] oh now we're going on
Halford which is the Paranormal show
well that's okay we were done we're done
no like in in um [__] in the song
Center [__] Halford is basically just
[__] he basically singing a [__]
love song to his [__]
[__] stylized [__] fantasy [__]
leather daddy which is this [__]
War demon that comes out of the ground
and [__] sets people on fire and
makes their blood boil just by thinking
about him and he just [__] soaks up
The Souls of the damn through all the
[__] all the battlefields of the
earth it's just masculine basket hyper
masculinity they're sexualizing hyper
masculinity only a gay dude could do it
only a leather dude could think that far
all right as a professional Soldier I'd
never come up with any [__] like that
is socializing he's sexualizing it how
sexy that is yeah not only the dudes
that are dying but these demons that are
getting off on it and making it happen
sexy and they're [__] yeah spreading
his [__] Wings Over the [__]
damned and [__] just it Halford is what
the [__] that demon
that's what he's singing about how he
loves that demon
something else intriguing that's his
mind is [__] you know yeah
yeah
that's also another sub genre yeah yeah
yeah demon [__] yeah
basically it's a love song of that demon
these things that's the ultimate dude
well a lot of his [__] songs are like
that the [__] Exciter was about that
just a [__] extra dimensional being
that comes down and [__] [__] up and
you know he believes it uh [__] the
painkillers like that all his songs were
like that
[__] um that's why they're
Supernatural Godlike dudes that [__]
[__] up and and [__] Halford loves it
that's his favorite thing his favorite
[__] thing Mark says turbo lever um
yeah Zach says a man knows what a man
wants yeah
I understand it yeah I don't [__] I
don't go that way but I understand it I
understand yeah
well yeah it's because it's just I was
gay it would definitely be that way it
definitely yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
would for sure yeah
[__] leather daddy I just take what I
want I don't give a [__] I don't care
I'm not going to jail about it roll over
compared to me you are a woman this
isn't even gay this is okay that's the
excuse me
right yeah whatever whatever time
whatever helps you sleep at night
just [__] with me no
no I just thought of this yeah I was at
work today and he um he sent me a
message and said
um what did you you said somebody it was
like an audio message and I couldn't
listen to it until later he said I'm
gonna cheat on you and go to koi
and I said oh food cheating you suck and
then he sent me like a little video of
him at koi one I was like you dirty
[__]
[Laughter]
video I was [__] making a big deal
about it I'm sitting there drinking
because we didn't go to koiwa this
weekend yeah like we usually go yep but
we didn't this weekend because we didn't
have a lot of money and it was just like
it's kind of far so we didn't go
but he went today on his motorcycle
while I was at work and I was like oh
you suck rubbing that [__] in too and he
was rubbing it
I'm cheating on you to go to court one
yeah where did it go oh [__]
[Laughter]
oh and then after that you said after
that you said I was like oh food
cheating and you said yeah no condom
either yeah yeah and then I said you
dirty [__] yeah yeah yeah
no condomination that attacks the
[__] shrimp I was gonna say he's like
raping the shrimp raping shoes they had
all those [__] you know the uh the
boiled shrimp the chilled boiled shrimp
and the cocktail sauce I get a whole
[__] plate of that but he will
actually actually I think last time we
wait you got two plates of that I did
one that started out and one to finish
up I got a big [__] plate like that
and I had a empty plate underneath it
for the shells yeah that's how we have a
whole system we got a whole system and
then squeeze a lemon on yourself yeah
you always take like two or three of
those ones so you can squeeze serious
yeah and then I went and got a whole
plate of steak because I had steak the
steak was good it was medium rare too
shrimp
and um I ate that like twice and then I
ate like three bowls of ice cream
goddamn little balls though every time
every time we go there like I can eat
like about a plate and a half and then
I'm like yeah I'm gonna barf and it's
like he just keeps eating and eating I'm
like where are you putting it my like my
my grandma used to say do you have a
hollow leg Yeah
I had that strawberry ice cream
and I'm eating it and I'm going this
isn't strawberry and the Chinese
waitress came by to pick up the plate
and I said what is this and she looked
at it and she goes and I go that's not
strawberry and she goes maybe raspberry
and I went no he's not raspberries that
take it that goes it's red because yeah
it's red it's red flavored red flavor
just chill out definitely not strawberry
well see it's mystifying because
sometimes they have ice cream in there
and they always have it's always eight
buckets and they usually have two of
each flavor they usually have green tea
uh chocolate vanilla strawberry maybe
yeah and butter pecan which is good
which is random but it's good because I
like butter pecan but the weird thing
and I've had mint chocolate chip in
there too though yeah but the last few
times we've been those have been the
flavors but then one time we went and
they had two red ones and you would
presume that they were both strawberry
but you ate one year like I'm pretty
sure this is Cherry and not strawberry
yeah and so now every time like he has
to sample both of the red ones and see
if they're the same well this was
another red one it didn't have any
strawberries in it it was not strawberry
it was red though
maybe it's red bean maybe that's what it
was maybe it's red bean it was something
foreign it didn't taste like any kind it
tasted like a fruit but not any kind of
fruit I've ever had it was just kind of
like real sweet
vanilla
with like there's just no way to
describe it red so it's probably maybe
it was red beans yeah because I kind of
feel like Cherry ice cream which they
don't have much Cherry ice cream is
usually white like with chunks of Cherry
in it is it not or like Cherry swirl no
it'll it'll be it'll be Cherry with
cherry in it yeah that one time was
Cherry Tammy said rhubarb oh yeah maybe
you think it was rhubarb there's no
telling it was just I was thinking red
bean because they have green tea flavor
there and sometimes they have like red
bean flavors it was just sweet it didn't
have any of the tartness of any kind of
fruit it was just kind of sweet huh I
was saying it almost kind of tastes a
little bit like rose
oh almost a rose flavor kind of maybe
that maybe that's what it was like a
honeycomb because I think they do have
like some don't in India don't they have
like a rose like with rosehip or
something like that it's just what it
kept reminding me of
like vanilla and Rose and a little bit
of Honey or something hmm that sounds
kind of good actually it was good it's
just it just wasn't strawberry it wasn't
fruit right Zach says Tom and Jen y'all
are total relationship goals
her total relationship goals what does
that mean that means that um that he
wants a relationship like we have who
said this exactly oh Zach yeah just
because I called you a dirty [__] for
going
yeah forgot a condom for God
they're back in it
bear back into the Chinese
were you like with the video like it
looked like nobody was in there but I
guess it's like they had me in the back
oh okay they put you in the bed they're
like you go in the background it was
full in the front
because that was Monday so I didn't know
if there was like it was crowded we had
a huge party
huge on a Monday yeah and it was Koreans
the Korean family I recognize the faces
and the size and I could hear a little
bit of Congo
Koreans yeah yeah and I saw I knew it
was it [__] confirmed it in my
[__] mind when the old man the oldest
of the oh they're all in suits like they
came back from church right so I'm not a
church thing because they're Christians
you know and it was some kind of church
thing or wedding Maybe
or you know some and the oldest of them
like the patriarch went walking and he's
walking stooped over with his hands
behind his back walking like a [__]
General and that's the damn Korean oh
yeah I know yeah I know what you're
talking about walking around his hands
clasp behind her back
like well I didn't like it like he's
running everything you know he's running
all this [__] he's in charge of it
this is all my [__] ready yeah yeah
everything is mine y'all gonna do what I
say you were only here because I'm
allowing you to be here
okay
Amy Says uh I'll do that to my husband
when I get back to Pennsylvania to visit
my mom I'll go to her favorite
restaurant and send him videos
food cheating that's what I call it
I just laughed because like I said he
sent me an audio message and I was in
the office so I couldn't listen to it
until I went outside then I went outside
and heard it I just busted up laughing
I'm gonna go cheat on you as I'm going
to koi one yeah
[Laughter]
uh it's left and left Zach says uh my
dad has been obsessed with coffee ice
cream this past year and it's the most
boring flavor ever to me I really like
coffee ice cream but generally if it's
got like chunks in I like like chocolate
with the beans like chocolate chunks in
it or with the beans in there too is
good too the coffee beans actually do
they have coffee flavored ice cream with
like chocolate covered Nespresso beans
in there oh probably because that would
be man it would make my eyeballs vibrate
but holy [__] it would be really good I
love chocolate covered espresso beans by
the way all right so I guess we're gonna
yeah we wrap this up because we're done
we're entertaining all these people
farting around
we're done farting around
um but yeah so uh yeah tomorrow night uh
I don't know maybe you might go to bike
night I gotta I gotta I got a zoom
meeting tomorrow night with us some
freelance work I gotta do
tomorrow night uh but Wednesday night is
our main show uh obviously and we're
gonna do more True Crime which you know
that's Jenny's favorite we're doing
Robert Hansen otherwise known as The
Butcher Baker I don't know the serial
killer okay you would probably he
Alaskan hunted people in the world okay
starting to sound familiar yeah 1960s or
70s I think it was you must have read
the most dangerous game yeah that's what
everybody says that but he's just yeah
yeah he seemed like a real uh prize but
um yeah he only just died in 2000 it was
women he was hunting yeah yeah he'd pick
up prostitutes Yeah well yeah hooker
hunting yeah that's what he was doing
they're bad I gotta punish him yeah
that's uh essentially yeah that's that's
the essence of the story right there I'm
trying to get a relationship up in this
[__] y'all selling the [__]
running into the ground [__]
everything up bending the wheels on it
[__] hubcaps flying off
it's supposed to be a fine car and
you're running it into the ground I'm
trying to protect [__] hubcap [__]
hubcaps flying off abusing it man like
me needs a relationship you're just
running into the ground over the money
y'all are bad that's the thinking
can we make [__] hubcaps of things yeah
[Laughter]
you could walk around wearing them Clank
Clank Clank
[Laughter]
yeah we better knock it off where he
gets anywhere before he gets any more uh
out of control all right so uh yeah be
sure to drop by on Wednesday we're gonna
talk about Robert Hansen the serial
killer so that should be a good show so
have a good rest of your evening you
guys and thanks for dropping by and
hanging out with us and we will see you
again on Wednesday good night